is there
you've already mentioned one but is
there a fight where
you've achieved the highest of heights
for your own personal being just when
you look within yourself
that you're the proudest of or maybe was
your most beautiful creation is this
something that stands out
there there are a few actually uh
fighting semi shield in a rematch
uh well the first one was pretty good
too uh but the rematch was
i i was suffering i had suffered early
prior
the week prior to uh food poisoning
and so while my abs are looking all
right
i in the ring didn't have
the power that i expected to and i was
struggling in ways in some of the
grappling for the submission stuff that
i hadn't accounted for just
exhaustion or mental exhaustion no i
mean like
just physical this i wasn't back up to
100 in terms of this power output
and semi was well he's always
seven foot tall but this time he was the
first time i fought him he was two
sixty or 257 or 260 something
something like that this time he was
like 290. and so he was a significantly
bigger cat
and he he was he's a big dude and
i just remember being
in up against the ropes with him
changing levels trying to take him down
and he's fighting he's hipping and i
just thought in my head there's no
[ __ ] way i'm going to lose this fight
there's no way you are not going to beat
me
it's not going to happen and i arm
barred him the other arm
even after the fact he's like man i
really want to get you for that i want
to get that match back and then you
[ __ ] got my other arm dick
dude i still love you though yeah you
know but the whole time you're
like so this has to do the the dichotomy
of your feeling
your worst and having to overcome and
you're like literally mentally telling
yourself there's no way
there's no [ __ ] way i'm gonna lose
this fight and then there's even my last
bare knuckle match
and getting in the ring and fighting
bare knuckle uh
boxing for the first time um
and just thinking just being in a great
state
and just just looking so forward to
seeing
i mean i called someone and i was
talking to them the night before and i
said yeah well
i i want you know i video called you
because this face might not look like
this
when i see you next and they're just
like uh
oh okay that's not just like empty trash
talk that's
no that's like a clarity of mind and the
seriousness of all i i know i might die
i'm most pretty high chance of of being
deformed some way
so but [ __ ] it i don't really are you do
you think about
are you accepting your own death yes 100
yeah i in fact and that's in a strange
way that's partially what
makes it so elevated in terms of my my
sense of
feeling by being able to
uh have death at my side
it feels good and to be there
and to think that this could be the one
like why not you know
uh i'm not a religious person at all
even though i
very much have to seem seems to bang on
the drama about the usefulness or the
understanding the usefulness of religion
for people
um but you know if if
if i got to do something then yeah put
me in valhalla man i don't want to be
anywhere else nothing else seems like a
good place for me to be i want to
i want to fight all day long and feast
all night you know it sounds great
you